so people should only be allowed to make
good choices no people should make the
choices that have good results hi I'm
Zack Weiss Muller for riesen TV we're
here in Charlotte North Carolina on day
one of the Democratic National
Convention we're going to talk to
Democratic delegates and supporters
about the issue of choice we want to see
if the respect for choice extends to
other areas of human activity besides
abortion one thing we're talking about
today here is choice the Democratic
platform strongly supports roe v-- wade
are you pro-choice
I'm absolutely pro-choice are you
pro-choice yes right why is choice an
important issue because a woman should
have a right to choose based on her
doctor and her family's decisions
there's been trans fat bans in certain
states bans on large sodas are you
pro-choice in terms of what you put in
your own body I think a lot of people
make harmful decisions there's alcohol
there's cigarette smoking and so I
understand the government trying to
intervene because the American taxpayer
pays a lot of money for fat people are
you Mississippi's the fattest state in
the Union and if anybody could use some
reduction in the trans fat intake
it would be my state so in that case
you're for taking away the consumer
choice absolutely
Chuck Schumer was pushing the ban of for
loca which is a combination of caffeine
and alcohol that seems like a clear
taking away of a choice would you not
agree with that well is it is it really
a choice you're deciding to do something
that's not healthy for you that's a
choice right but if you decide to do
something that's not healthy for you
let's talk about the results of that
action that you take so people should
only be allowed to make good choices no
people should make the choices that have
good results should consumers have a
choice in what kind of light bulbs they
want to buy no they shouldn't because if
they're polluting the earth it's gonna
last longer than their lifetime you're
okay with restricting choice when light
bulbs yeah and even if you do prefer the
warm glow if you're that particular
about lighting does that really come
before the safety and future of our
planet to choose
not to be in the Union there's not a
choice that should be maybe a choice not
to be in the Union yep so you're in
favor of rights works no I
well you choice not to be in the Union
but I think unions do good so I would -
I I guess not I'm not in favor of right
to work should people have the choice
not to join a union actually no I don't
like the right-to-work states you're
from Louisiana
what about school choice the the choice
of parents - to send their kids to
whatever school they think is best
well I think if you had reasonable
schools that were held to accountability
and and used a reasonable curriculum I
think it would be a wonderful thing
there are a lot of for-profit charter
schools there it's the profit motive of
a bad thing I think the profit motive is
not something that should be interjected
into public education
I'm a BD all but dissertation alright it
was hard enough for me to navigate my
child through her educational progress
right when you're talking about people
who for no reason of their own are
unable to understand the educational
system yes I think there ought to be
some regulations in place to help those
parents and to provide for the future of
their children but you are pro-choice
I'm definitely pro-choice when it comes
to people's bodies I do want to
reiterate your you are pro-choice though
I'm pro-choice on everything about
everything about everything the person
should have a right to choose but there
should be not an informed choice and
government has a role in there so maybe
there's some contradictions but people
are made up of consultations you're
pro-choice I'm Pro intervention gotcha